let the excommunication begin how many
people here have read this book it's a
like 15 people okay cool
how many people know of this book
alright cool
so you're like me like you know this
classic you haven't read it that's fine
this talk is not going to be a technical
talk at all I have a few slides that are
gonna be code but most of it is just
gonna be a brain dump of the last two
years of working in industry at clarinha
so what is this talk not let's see if I
can switch slides there we go it's not a
talk that will leave you saying like ah
yes I'm gonna use this one tool and it's
gonna solve all of my problems that's
not the point of this talk at all so a
little bit about me I used to actually
work in this building or not this one in
particular but one over there
after I finished my Master's I went here
to be a part of the lab the lamp lab and
we worked on the Dali compiler or as
it's now known I guess this Godfrey
compiler so then I decided I want to
really live with my girlfriend in
Stockholm those huge thing for me and I
started work at this interesting company
called clarinha and what do i do there
well I write Haskell for Snoop Dog which
is a really nice thing we have this
pretty cool
commercial let's see if it actually will
slow down this Wi-Fi that's always an
interesting thing anyway like the
commercial depict snoop he's like he
goes up and he gets coronated as smooth
the dog which is like our motto that
clarinha everything is supposed to be
smooth for the customer and you can
actually come to our offices and you can
try on these really cool rings so if
you're ever by Stockholm and give me a
I wanted to sort of also have like a
historical aspect to this talk like
depicting how we as a company went from
doing essentially Java services on to
doing like purely functional Scala and
then later on now something different
and this I really like this picture in
the bottom left the evolution of man
into like a lambda man or something like
this this which I've obviously stolen
from Oscar so up until sort of like 2014
Clara was mainly doing Java on late at
least on on the micro-services side
we've always had like this huge monolith
in Erlang which is really incredible
piece of technology and if you're
interested in Erlang or the actor model
then it's it's a really interesting
system but there were some issues with
that system and it kept crashing so they
they decided like we should just you
know break this model at the part we
should have micro services they should
all be you written in Java with spring
and so on all those scary things all the
beans were there I think and then at
some point in 2015 there was this one
engineer who said I'm gonna quit if I
don't get to write this next service in
Scala and it turned out that this guy
was pretty important to the company so
managers was like damn ok well let this
guy write the thing in Scala and they
started small
you know like with not invented here
syndrome they started with writing
something that was basically you know
Java without the semicolons I think
we've all been there some points the
next thing they did when they sort of
started getting their toes wet a bit
more was to start building this
framework for event sourcing and after a
while they were sort of like now we're
more comfortable with Scala the language
we feel that we know like how to write
idiomatic code so then they took like
the services that were they were writing
in Drock wizard in spring but--and
started like creating wrappers around
those to make the use of those frame
more idiomatic and of course like they
wrote the second event sourcing library
because you know why not and then they
wrote the third one and this woman is
really funny because it's called it's
called Fest which in Swedish means party
and it was supposed to be like a
functional event sourcing toolkit but
the problem was like it was neither
functional as an FP or functional acid
and it worked that's always something
right all right and then in 2017 I was
introduced to the company and I'm not
sure there's causation but definitely
correlation that the team's decided to
go fully functional so we decided to go
like purely functional Scala we were
writing our services in what we call the
type level stack and I'm sure you would
agree so HTTP 4s do B etc so we had
three teams or so that collaborated
around this stack and built like sort of
the necessary infrastructure in order
for clarinha to do its business you know
it's stupid things like auth extraction
of certain headers etc and of course
like we we could not not write another
event sourcing library so I wrote one
actually I responsible for this one I'm
sorry
it's called blunts and it's based on
Rob's dooby it's about like 500 lines or
so like it's really small and it works
incredibly well so yeah we haven't open
sourced this and I'm sorry like we
should have but I just don't want to
maintain more code so that's why if
you're interested like I can zip it and
send it to you so then you can talk to
me afterwards but so the reason like why
we like we we've all made this like
journey towards going more and more
functional and clarinha and the
engineers of clarinha are really happy
doing purely functional programming and
this is sort of like the quintessential
thing about their journeys like the more
functional stuff we did the more certain
we felt that our code was working there
was
doing the things that were supposed to
which makes this next section so hard I
want to sort of preface this with saying
that I still love Scala I really love
Scala the language and for me it's it
will probably always be like the go-to
language it's the one I'm the most
proficient in but there are some odd
ends when doing a purely functional
programming in Scala so let's talk pros
and cons so one of the pros is that it's
on it's compatible with Java it's on the
JVM and I think we can all sort of agree
that the initial part of skål success
was due to it being on the JVM with all
the libraries etc being available from
from the get-go but maybe that's just it
from a purely functional programming
perspective that's what we care about we
care about having a mature ecosystem the
other thing we really enjoy about
writing things in Scala is how easy it
is to make errors appear in the type so
using things like either T's or either's
whatever these Mon are constructs might
be that encapsulate its errors in the
way that we care about
and the other thing we like is like not
banging strings together that shouldn't
be banked together so having a new type
wrappers it's also something that's very
valuable to us as programmers and in
doing purely functional programming
they're sort of this there's this
feature to it where if you make all your
errors appear in the types you sort of
have a form of effect tracking inside
your system which means that you really
only need to do edge validation which is
sort of the killer feature of functional
programming I think and the other Pro is
you guys are you folks there's a very
strong community around functional
programming in Scala and there are many
opinions that might be differing in some
cases but I think that just makes the
entire case stronger for for doing a
functional programming in Scala that so
many people care about it
so what about the drawbacks them to
doing purely functional programming
scoff well as we mentioned it's on the
JVM and for us doing purely functional
programming and having to interact with
Java that sort of means that we have the
wrapper wrapped a lot of side affecting
code we have to take care of that
manually and maintain those wrappers the
other thing that I really say with the
heavy heart is that teaching purely
functional programming in Scala is hard
I've like initially that was my job at
Clara teaching our engineers how to do
purely functional programming in Scala
and this turns out to be non-trivial I
mean we had some success cases for
instance my boss I'm gonna shame him a
bit here my boss did not know of the
keyword var until six months into our
project pretty happy with that one but
there are some others like some syntax
for instance that's you you have to keep
explaining over and over to people like
what does this underscore do here like
what does it mean here what does it mean
here what does it mean here there are so
many things you have to teach and there
are other all ends for purely functional
programming with things like kind
projector how many people here have
explained kind projector to one of their
colleagues yes most of you
excellent how many people think they got
it the first time maybe not so the thing
is like in in other languages where you
have a carrying of tie parameters or
types really this is not an advanced
feature it's more of a basic feature
that you that we talk about so that's
one thing that I think is really hard
with teaching it the other thing is that
Scala is unopp Enya nated if we want to
do a very strict subset of Scala the
purely functional subset of Scala then
we have to teach people what not to use
which is much harder than saying like
here's a language just use it however
you weigh when it comes to how IO works
we had some big issues with this
actually how many people know that JDBC
is blocking one person is least good all
of you excellent
so if you have a web service that's
fully asynchronous you sort of want to
split execution between two different
thread pools right so we had this one
service team was pulling up and they
were essentially they were doing the
right thing in the application code but
when they called to the database they
would shift it to the blocking thread
pool good and then they would shift it
back to the blocking thread pool they
didn't know which thread pool they were
shifting it onto so we sort of starved
at one thread pool we just put all the
threads onto it whenever something
touched the database we just moved all
the threads over there which is really
hard to see in code and you can you can
sort of a new-type your way around this
to have like one type for the blocking
and one type for the non blocking but
it's still an unclear thing to see in
the code you don't actually see where
things are executing and the other thing
is type inference with FB in Scala I
think we've all been there where we're
like the compiler should get this and
we're like we and we we explicitly put
the arguments under the compiler agrees
with us I mean this is much better in
Scala 3 in my opinion but it's still
something that's pervasive in Scala -
all right and I have this opinion that I
think is sort of in popular or unpopular
is that I don't think that purely
functional programming is idiomatic -
Scala the way we're doing it right now
and I think a lot of the reason why
doesn't is because we took a lot of
concepts from Haskell and copy them
verbatim onto Scala and this is an area
where we as a community need to
experiment and improve I think that the
things that are done with intersection
types in z io for instance is one of
those things that sort of moves the
needle in the right direction using the
features of the language to make
functional programming more ergonomic
all right I I still want to say that I
really love this language asked as a
power user it's the best possible
language you can have you can mold the
language to be exactly what you want it
to be and that is something that at
least I greatly appreciate about
language and as a library author that's
something I'm sure most people here
would agree with all right no tomatoes
yep
cool all right so this is our CEO I'm
pretty sure this is Photoshop like I'm
he's not that athletic I'm I'll be fired
for this but anyway so he said this he
said like clarinha is gonna be the AWS
of banking so what he meant with this
was like if you are a fin tech startup
and you want to have banking
capabilities you should be able to go to
us use our banking license and then just
you know bootstrap your services so okay
cool great
the problem is that my team has to build
this so my team is called the buckaroos
and we're part of the core banking
domain and at clarinha where we are a
team responsible for inter ledger
transactions that means that we move
money from or between different Ledger's
in systems and when I was given this
task of starting this team me and my
colleagues we were debating like what's
that should we use like should we
continue with the type level stack
should we adopt something else and we
sort of came to this folly aware like
let's try to create our utopia let's try
to create something that's even better
than what we had before we knew what we
loved about functional programming type
level Scala and we also knew what we
didn't like so in trying to or in
wanting to stay in the purely functional
world we decided that the next stepping
stone in this direction would be to
actually use a purely functional
language so that's what we decided to do
and we also decided to expand our
novelty budget and use this thing called
serverless why not write like you gotta
expand the service budgets
we're deeply invested in AWS by the way
so we're using their version of service
and we started this project by using
these three technologies really so we're
using NYX as like a four we have a mono
repo so we use NYX to manage all the
dependencies in this we use it to get
reproducible builds and so on
we chose pure script initially and I'll
tell you why we might away from that in
a bit
pure script is a language that's very
similar to Haskell but it's it compiles
to do JavaScript so it can use with
nodejs
which was at the time one of the few
supported runtimes for AWS service and
we use terraform for deployment in this
mono repo there are a bunch of other
languages so we have a bunch of closure
we have a bunch of Python you name it
alright so the deployment strategy for
this repo is is something that really
matters here because what we're building
is like a white label solution where we
have to be able to like redeploy the
world which also gives us some really
nice features because if we build a
platform in the correct way we can
deploy the world when we want to test
something which is a really neat feature
you can test how everything would
interact in the cloud so we have this
concept of environment test which is
just this we spin up an entire
environment the complete platform for
everything through a building and then
you can run your tests against those
services so then we have the usual sort
of strategy where you know you have a
branch you do this environment test do
the system test the unit tests you name
it and then we merge that the master if
we are at the head of the branch we
don't actually have to retest anything
we can simply promote to staging and
from staging we'll just go to production
so you can see we have these four zones
of deployment eu-us staging and
production all right so that's sort of
the premise right so once we have this
now we sort of have to decide how to FP
+ igoogle confused and this guy came up
I've no idea why but seems like he would
have a hard time choosing between
tagless final empty
free monads and hands and patterns or
whatever so here's the thing all these
diets work if you'd if you want to do
one of these then commit to it don't go
halfway and also my advice is to make it
easy for yourself someone once told me
that when you write code you have to be
twice as smart when you're debugging the
code so if you write the code in the
most smart way possible then you're
gonna have hell when you're trying to
debug it so pick something that you
really understand when you do this and
part of this goes like into the novelty
budget I was talking about before and
you can't like if you have a new
greenfield project like this you can't
really waste things on things you don't
understand
of course like we did not follow this at
all and we chose to do all of these
things like why not so we we started
with two handler patterns and then we
did reader for a while then we did this
really cool thing in pure script it's
called row type polymorphic functions
and then of course like you gotta have
tagos finals I mean we're all hipsters
here right and real type polymorphism is
something I just wanted to show really
quickly because it's a pretty cool
concept
so in in pure script you can actually
have like an alias for a specific row
inside the record so you can say like I
have a record here that's persist the
TAS a specific field called persist that
ask the function signature a to a half
of unit and you don't really have to
know what F is if you equate that with
IO but it's the sort of pure get variant
of that and this is really neat because
this allows you to sort of empower
functions so in the function that you
see here at the bottom to do persist and
call back you can say that this one
takes a record which has a field
persistable payment and something that's
called back double this means that we
sort of we can empower functions to have
certain traits
or actually certain capabilities so that
means that we can sort of limit the
scope very much in what we have to test
for each function and as you can see
like we're passing this it's like this
Union type here where we pass some are
at the end so we don't really care about
the other fields we just say stating
simply that we want these two
capabilities at least for the thing
that's passed into the do persistent
callback function so this would be
something that's equivalent to the
handler pattern but then uses a function
of the language which is pretty cool all
right so we had this and then we went
through this so what happened really
well why did we switch it all comes back
to this novelty budget that I was
talking about before
pure script is a really cool language
and it improves on Haskell in a number
of ways one of which is that it has the
dot operator which is something that
sounds very trivial to anyone who's done
like C syntax style programming before
but the dot operator in Haskell doesn't
exist the dot operate in Haskell is
function composition so having this
imperious actually sometimes really nice
on the other hand pure script has sort
of positioned itself as being a
front-end language which means that
there isn't that much support for doing
back in things and my team is sort of
like we're the backends backends
back-end so we don't ever see front-end
code which to me is really awesome but
it also means that pure script might not
be the best fit for the things that
we're doing it ends up with us having to
maintain all these wrapper functions
calling into node.js libraries and then
we're sort of back to the same thing we
had with a purely functional Scott lot
where we had to maintain all these
wrappers to JVM libraries so that's that
was something that was eating our time
really and the thing is like Haskell is
just so much more mature than pure
script and I sort of feel that one of
the reasons why we can say this is
because it took us one week to rewrite
an application we'd written for six
months
it's a really cool thing and part of
this I believe is because it is a purely
functional application and that pure
script is sort of like a dialect of
Haskell
not really the other thing that we
stopped doing was the service stuff so
serverless is a really interesting
concept and I do believe in a few years
time it will be the it will be the
de-facto way of doing things but right
now it's sort of not really there you
have to test the entire application to
make sure that things are working which
is something that's not economic it
doesn't give you that fast feedback loop
that you want as a developer and also
this thing we had before where I said oh
it took 16 minutes to deploy well that
was a lie because we were not able to
parallelize this for various reasons so
these are actually sequential so then
that would mean that the pipeline took
something like 25 minutes run we
eventually got this down to six minutes
so now we're running like easy two
containers servant applications and we
do component tests and integration tests
all locally in docker ice-t-- way all
right
so how do we write code now well this is
the gist of it we use Tyler's final like
this to sort of empower each function so
you can see the handle requests here
it's literally only able to do these
things that are in the requirements list
here it's only able to persist things
it's only able to respond it's only able
to log it can't do anything else having
having this amount of control really
really minimizes the scope of what each
function can do and that's something
that's incredibly powerful and that we
were very happy with I was planning on
showing more of like how we deal with
this and how this is implemented but I
think we're gonna have to cut that a bit
short I'll speed through it instead so
what you do is like you define these
type classes like this that becomes your
interface and then you use those
functions
the implemented function so having
handle requests like this the first
thing you do is you pattern match on
what type of request it is then you can
say I want to persist the transaction
and then you can put a typed hole how
school will tell you what's the type of
this what's expected then you say I want
to respond with either error or created
depending on the outcome of the first
function all right and then there is a
short example of how to implement the
persist the Monad persist interface here
and it's a pretty simple thing the nice
thing to note here is that the
requirements for building an instance of
this is that you have a database
connection through some R and that
you're able to log that's it all right
and testing is simply new type wrapping
the instance and stubbing out the things
you don't care about which is really
good so the pros and cons of doing
Haskell is like the record thing is
really a big deal actually like you
early on your you'll name your fields
inside the records things like amount
currency but then that turns out to be a
horrible idea because records are
actually just syntactic sugar for
functions on to products so terrible
idea if you know about this up front you
will of course prefix everything nicely
and you'll have lenses and so on derived
automatically for these types but that's
something that we as a team did not
invest in from the get-go the other
thing is extensions you sort of have to
align in the team on which extensions
you use some are some change to type
inference and we'll change the meaning
of your program others are very
innocuous like overload the strings
that's something that I think every high
school programmer uses the other thing
is like the great build tool war it's
always nice to have we're not all right
so there are some other got just too
using hospital for instance the capital
library is based on labardi Kafka which
is a sea library that's fully
asynchronous which is really cool
because it's incredibly fast
on the other hand the callback type lies
to you it sort of tells you that you get
back like when you send something you
get back in of maybe half care so if you
get back nothing then everything went
fine no that's not true it's like if you
get back nothing then that means that
the pre-flight checks worked out but it
will actually error when it's trying to
send it on a different thread pool so
yeah those are some things to watch out
for but the pros then so we sort of get
the same same features as we got with
purely functional Scala where we're able
to refactor our entire code base without
fear of breaking anything we get
something that's very performant we
don't get any cold starts which for us
in the FinTech industry is something
that's a non-starter like we have to
respond within a certain time frame if
you have like three instances that will
call each other and you have a
dependency on like the latency can't be
more than two seconds and all of these
instances are cold
yeah not gonna be fun you're gonna lose
income all right and the ecosystem is
really great all the libraries that you
could possibly want they exist and the
last thing that is important to me is
that it's training people on Haskell is
shockingly easier it takes us I think
three to four weeks to get people fully
productive whereas with purely
functional Scala it took us months so
that's sort of like the biggest thing
and in the end you have to ask yourself
what are you optimizing for me I'm
optimizing for my team and them staying
productive and for us Haskell is just a
solution for you it might be something
different thank you very much
[Applause]
okay we have time for one quick question
while the next speaker setting up how
big is your cut base how big is my code
base so we run micro-services right so I
think our our main Haskell product now
is about ten thousand lines of code and
then we're we have different services
that are smaller than that okay it was
very quick maybe another quick question
okay then thanks for Felix
[Applause]